president Ashraf Ghani buoyed by his
status as the front-runner just a month
out from Afghanistan's presidential
elections this campaign rally is
targeting the private sector not shekhar
amman I are here is play their role in
the battleground but the fight of our
financial freedom and independence is
through the private sector the private
sector is fighting this fight its
ghani's sixth rally all but one have
been inside this highly secure building
known as the Loya Jirga tent
there are sixteen candidates but fewer
campaigning openly because of security
threats the campaign season started on
July 28th within hours the Taliban
launched an attack on the office of
ghani's running mate Andrew LaSalle a
more than 20 people died the Taliban has
warned people they may also target
campaign rallies calling the vote a sham
talks between the US and Taliban a pitch
to stop such attacks you'd they too are
threatening elections if a deal has
agreed many candidates are skeptical
elections will go ahead so they're not
spending much on their campaigns this is
one of the few streets in Kabul where
campaign posters have been put up rahmat
allah nabiyeen Ghani and is a former
National Intelligence chief he worries
an election will further divide Afghan
politicians when they should have a
united front ahead of potential talks
with the Taliban we only have very weak
and marginalized government we already
have very divided politicians that was
why I say that if you don't manage the
election properly the main winner will
go to tal about many Afghans are also
skeptical and a recent observer survey
nearly 60 percent of Afghans said they
would boycott the vote the Election
Commission is charging forward march mad
within my house the elections must take
place it is a red line for us we are
fully prepared Afghans really need peace
so we are going forward simultaneously
but I'm 40
the peace process is overshadowing the
election and may affect voter enthusiasm
voter enthusiasm is not a problem for
President Ghani being ahead in the polls
he could very well be closing in on
another five years undeterred by Taliban
peace negotiations or their attacks
Charlotte Bellis al Jazeera Kabul